sa già che porti così vince ogni volta
che parte un gioco del genere non
capisco si sta partendo cosa boe giorno
salve per farmi produrre nel mentre che
ti alzi che fai colazione va bene bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo sul limbo
non ha un menù perché è un gioco
alternativo è un gioco trasgressori care
anche col joystick quindi viva me che
sono pigro p introduca un secondo
ragazzi prima di cominciare perché
almeno facciamo le cose con ordine
allora innanzitutto scusatemi se la voce
tipo quella di un robot ma fino a ieri
ha avuto la febbre a 40 ora la febbre mi
è passata però devo indossare questo
sacco dell'immondizia perché sennò
prendo freddo e inoltre mi è rimasta la
tosse il naso chiuso quindi se parlo di
merda e c'è più di merda del solito e
perché ho l'influenza bene in aggiunta a
tutto questo le mie cuffie si sono
scassate e quindi devo usare queste che
fanno un po schifo di estetica però
sfiga tanto l'immondizia addosso quindi
non fa niente siamo sul limbo è
bellissimo perché io l'avevo già giocato
molto tempo fa tantissimo tempo fa però
lo voglia di giocare per voi ragazzi
perché quando ho finito inside che era
della stessa casa di produzione di limbo
ho detto mi che ho fatto inside e non ho
fatto limbo che è stato il primo gioco
della casa che ha fatto anche inside
venditori a devo fare prima questo e poi
inside invece ho fatto il contrario però
chi mi prende sul serio tanto indosso ai
sacchi dell'immondizia più o meno è la
stessa cosa di inside sono un po meno
colorato corato molto meno colorato cioè
non ci avevano voglia di mettere i
colori allora hanno detto massi sti
caxxi mettiamo tutto in bianco e nero e
va bene tanto il tipo che chi è che sto
comandando ai capelli che sono uguali ai
miei
a un certo punto di vista comunque una
figata allora io ve lo dico ragazzi
questo sarà un gioco molto molto simile
ad inside è bellissimo mi ricordo che
avevo giocato e mi è piaciuto tantissimo
non so se è più bello di inside o meno
però è molto simile da un certo punto di
vista quindi se vi è piaciuto inside
visto che vi è piaciuto ma diventa tutti
credo che vi piacerà anche questo anche
se un po più vecchio ma è molto molto
figo dato non ho mai capito se c'era il
gioco si chiama limbo no quindi in
teoria dovremmo essere nel limbo che se
non sapete cos'è dove trainare la barca
vero ma trova in macchie genio che
[ __ ] c'è questo bambino che che forza
cia nelle braccia lo sa solo lui perché
mi chiamo spinaci a go go per trainare
una barca sulla terra però va bene
sticazzi comunque e vedete che è molto
simile ad inside da molti punti di vista
tipo tarzan bene secondo me ragazzi il
sacco dell'immondizia che ho addosso mi
conferisce più punti abilità nel
risolvere gli enigmi che comunque mi
servirà un sacco in stock gameplay se
voglio andare avanti quindi va bene
quanto è brutto sembra la cosa più
preziosa di
[Musica]
il bello ragazzi che non era un enigma
questo devono semplicemente non essere
orbo però non l'ho visto quindi va bene
come come dovrei fare spiega cos'è non
riesco come come faccio ma sono trappole
per orsi chi cazzo ammesso delle
trappole per orsi lo stare in mezzo non
devo saltare in mezzo cosa devo fare
ma appena partiti già non son capace
fantastico io io lo sapevo solo che non
volevo vedere se ci arrivate prima voi
però non ci siete arrivati mi dispiace
se siete scarsi comunque ragazzi la cosa
triste che non mi ricorderò niente ma
zero di tutto dico che sto facendo e il
gioco io l'ho già detto già fatto e
questo è questa la cosa triste è che c'è
cos'è un corpo morto sembra un'attività
affanculo mi son caga tissimo aprendo
questo momento qua il salto di non così
giusto o le come cazzo arrivo lassù a ok
era più semplice del previsto
bene allora ragazzi io ve lo dico me lo
sto per giocare tutto quindi in tutti
gli episodi che vedrete ci ha proposto
sacco e avrò st voce di merda perché io
gioco tutto oggi e poi divido in vari
video quindi se mi date dei consigli non
non serva un cazzo perché l'ho già
giocato però nel mentre sfogate mi sa
dire quanto sono è bene non riuscire a
farli
un volervi c'è una cosa sola che io mi
ricordo in questo gioco una quando la
vedrete ve lo dirò
ma a fuoco a nuoto lo ha fatto bene in
inside e non affogare ci hanno messo 5
anni a fare insight con inside potevi
nuotare ci hanno messo 5 anni aggiungere
la feature del nuoto nei giochi ragazzi
non serviva per l'acqua ma ovviamente
essendo bucata col cazzo che galleggia
però non contatti e troppo sull'ambiente
licenza ragazzi non so quanto vi
convenga ok ma non ci arriva ma non ci
arriva neanche tarzan nella gioia e
invece non pensavo sai mi chiamassi 6
atletico ragazzo complimenti dalla
chiavi per avere due anni o anche meno
forse quantità di amia e devo puntare su
tutto stradi con le montagne jolo
ma devo scendere piano mi ammazzo
no dai zio che due palle va bene prima o
poi avrei dovuto scoprire uno visto che
ci giocherò per sempre che cancella su
come faceva di varela
cos'è quella roba là c'è una c'è una
roba che non capisco che va va bene sarà
uno di quegli oggetti che più ne
raccoglie i più completi il gioco e le
sfide però non me ne frega un cazzo
quindi a me già è tanto se finisco il
gioco figurati se raccolgo i
collezionabili zio c però non ci arriva
lo stesso
così grazie di dio perfette quant'è
brutto piva davanti che lo fareste
brutta ragazzi madonna ma c'è
grazie
c'è una trappola su un albero come
dovrei prenderla spiega è un ragno se
non si possono dato
ebbene proprio per questo mi ricordavo
questo gioco andrà a mi ha fatto cadere
la trappola grazie ragazzi perché io
sono un [ __ ] perché sono un [ __ ]
qualcuno mi spiega perchè sono un
[ __ ] perché voglio saperlo c'è un
motivo o racca di quella tutta a grazie
la cosa che vi stavo per dire ma per
l'euforia sono morto e che questa che
state per vedere una delle scene che mi
ha dato più soddisfazione nella storia
dei videogame segnalare medaglie quanto
mi dispiace dice che bella sensazione
quando fai del male a un ragno
[ __ ] e bellissimo quando fai del
male a un ragno di morire tutti non
bruciarli bruciare nelle tue stesse
zamaro testa di culo qui tra l'altro non
è che
il karma il karma c'è poi tra l'altro
ragazzi sto ragno non è neanche tanto
più grande di quello che avevo in casa
mia qualche anno fa voi sapete di cosa
sto parlando
e melo pupi tutto europea è così è
successo
si sta anche a chi è venuto madonna
tranquilli non è finita qua purtroppo
ecco ragazzi questa era l'unica cosa che
mi ricordavo di tutto il gioco ma in
generale l'unica proseguiamo andiamo
avanti
e stato bello che poi bellissimo ragazzi
che hanno scelto proprio ragni o tra
tutti i boss possibili che potevano
scegliere il gioco va il ragno hanno
scelto nè che poi il serpente le
farfalle i ragni grazie cazzo è stata no
no no frate non hai capito un cazzo ti
devi muovere che gioco di merda bene
ecco questo non me lo ricordavo per
niente lavori mosso che schifo santo di
dio
e vabbè vabbè che madonna che brutta
cosa sto vedendo
te ne stai andare grazie a dio si è
rincoglionito e te ne stai andando ma
grazie a dio è bene quella che si suol
dire una giornata di merda fantastico ma
se mi muovo mi libero ah si mi fa un po
schifo come resistenza lato ragnatela
ciclo però va beh forse pensavi che non
mi sarei mosso è stato il bello che non
sto vedendo dove sto andando mascot
saltando però va bene stato qualsiasi
posto è meglio di quello di prima
perfetto aggiungiamo ragazzi uno sport
olimpionico il salto nel box solo chi
salta più il salto in lungo col bozzolo
chi salta piu in avanti col bosforo
potrebbe essere un'idea che dite sì ma
come mi libero da sta roba fra temi
numero dc non spingere la palma nomi
libero da non so perchè ma mi ha fatto
ridere sta roba sono sadico a basta che
la faccia roteare giudici beh affetto
non è così difficile per adesso è un
buon non vorrei dirvi stronzate però il
teoria per adesso è fattibile perché io
non sto zitto nella mia vita porca di
una lercia eva sta roba ma metà già
fatemi capire messaggio come lo devo
fare tutto imbozzolato non ho capito è
sempre comunque più elegante lui di me
in questo momento con questa roba che ci
addosso però dettagli
va bene no frate no frate dai cazzo devi
pagare un po di meno e le palle che lo
dico patti chiari amicizia lunga
facendo mi prendi per il culo perché va
lento vuole farmi soffrire lentamente so
stronzo cosa come ho fatto a liberarvi
non ho capito sta cosa di come ho fatto
a liberarmi però va bene io ti è rimasto
uno spermatozoo sull'orecchio dovresti
toglierlo ma vabbè dai ti sta anche
abbastanza bene
salve vengo in pace e quello che ho in
testa non è mio era di un altro giuro ah
ok forse lui se la sta spassando un po
meno di me però dettagli
allora che faccio prendo questo no
perché la prima idea che ciò è sempre
quella sbagliata qual è il mio problema
è che non so cosa mi chiedevo fare il
matto diana jones può accompagnare solo
è andata veramente di culo ragazzi
perché non ci sarei mai riuscito c'è lo
provate a caso più perfetto bebè neva
andiamo avanti che figata il fatto che
devo saltare da un tronco all'altro
bellissimo perché mi fanno spingere i
tronchi in questo gioco che problema c'è
forse perché non dovevo spiava potevate
essere un po meno tragici e sadici
maledetti creatori del gioco perfetto
amica meno male che sono sempre magroni
videogiochi sono col cazzo che ci
passavo
e il signore degli anelli accompagna
solo anche su questa cosa ragazzi che
avevo fatto giusto perché avevo fatto
giusto sono morto lo stesso minchia
sarebbe stato bellissimo riuscire a
primo tentativo una cosa del genere
luca ragazzi per chi non conoscesse a
cena del signore degli anelli c'è
perdete tutta la mia stima
bene devo capire come fados a fermo qua
ma c'erano il sito come fatta sbagliare
miglia sarebbe stato bellissimo
riuscirci al primo tentativo ragno o tv
dico solo che sono convinto non me lo
ricordo è nord up sono convinto
ho giocato talmente tanti giochi che so
già quello che succede a prescindere
lo sapevo lo sapevo
è un ragno fake e ora è un re un ragno
fake non va ma vale lo stesso cielo
azzeccato lo stesso e questo è molto
meno sacco di immondizia dei colori
prima però questa altro che sto facendo
l'ho fatta dopo molto dopo aver
registrato limbo sì mi è passata la
febbre nel mentre ma negli altri episodi
di limbo avevo ancora la febbre quindi
mi vedrete sempre con quel sacco di
immondizia e sti cazzi comunque sia
ragazzi che lui sia piaciuto come sento
dire prigione l'argomento non mi piace
anche i vari social che come descrizione
sui giardini siete rich vediamo al
prossimo limbo e da ragazzi non mi
ricordavo più il mio finale dei video
ecco che giocare a sta roba mi fa male
al cervello che non ho bella